Baseball, the American pastime. Stolen bases, home runs, grand
slams, hot dogs and nachos. These are some of the things that make a baseball game
fun.
Part of the experience, of course, is yelling at the umpires.
And let's face it, they're going to make a lot of mistakes.
They're human. When they make a bad call or they miss a call, we let them have it.
But what if there were a perfect umpire?
This umpire got calls correct one hundred percent of the time.
You know with modern technology today we can almost do this.
We can tell if a pitch is a strike or a ball, or if a runner is safe or out.
If an umpire had that knowledge would we listen to this umpire?
The answer is of course we would.
Now a call from our perspective might seem like they got it wrong but given that
this umpire is correct 100% of the time, we would always know that the umpire got
the call right. Human beings differ wildly on all sorts of social, ethical,
scientific, and theological issues.
But what if there was an umpire that was always correct, especially on spiritual
issues? This umpire never got it wrong.
Would we listen to that person?
Some time ago, I went with my wife and my pastor to meet a group of skeptics,
atheists, and agnostics. Towards the end of the meeting, my pastor asked a really
interesting question. He said to this group of people who don't believe in God, he
said if there were a God, would his opinion be more valuable than yours?
And to me, the answer seems obvious.
If there's a God who spoke all of creation into existence and knows everything,
then of course his opinion is more valuable than mine.
This group of people hesitated and eventually they said no.
Even if there were a God, his opinion would not be more important or authoritative
than theirs.
This gets to the heart of the matter of authority in our world.
Who do we trust? Now we would trust a perfect umpire and this umpire would have
authority because he or she would never make the wrong call.
Well, the same is true with God.
If there is a God, and this God by definition is self-existent, eternal, perfectly
good, loving, and knows everything, then by definition, this God is gonna
make the right call. Now it might seem from our perspective that God has made the
wrong call, but if we stopped and focused on the character of God, we would know
that the problem is not with the call, that the problem is with our perspective.
Recently I was invited to participate in a public conversation with a former pastor
who's become an atheist and he asked some good questions such as how could a loving
God send somebody to hell or why would God have his chosen people in the Old
Testament engage in warfare? These are thoughtful questions that every Christian
needs to wrestle with. But rather than answer his particular questions, as important
as they are, I wanted to frame the conversation differently.
I said that any adequate worldview has to account for certain big features in
reality. Any adequate worldview has to explain certain big questions we have about
life, such as why is the universe so exquisitely fine-tuned for life?
What best explains the origin of information and DNA?
And what worldview can account for the origin of things like objective beauty,
morality, and free will? The reality is that atheism can't answer any
of the big questions of life. But Christianity can.
What this means is that if Christianity is true, then we can trust that God is the
authority for all of life. Are there some tough questions that remain like this
pastor asks? Yes. but we can trust that God exists and God is good and he has
reasons why even if he doesn't always fully reveal those reasons to us.
Jesus believed that God's word was authoritative for all of life.
That's why when he was asked tough questions, he often responded by saying, have you
not heard or have you not read?
Appealing to the Old Testament because he believed that God's word was reliable
and authoritative in everything that it taught.
If
God does exist, then his opinion is supreme, even if we don't understand it.
Like the umpire we mentioned who never missed a call.
God never makes mistakes. The question is, will we listen to him?
This is not an apologetic issue or argument.
This is just a deep question we need to wrestle with personally in our own lives.
Who are we going to look to as the authority?
The only way we can be right with God and experience the abundant life that Jesus
promised is by following God's guide for our lives as found in the scriptures.
Many people in our world will say that the Bible is antiquated or God is a cosmic
killjoy, but this isn't true. God's commandments and teachings exist for our good.
God has our best in mind. So regardless of how you feel or
how things appear to be in your life, the question is will you trust God as the
ultimate authority in your life?
It's hard to imagine a question more important than this.